zordi l'autre famille doit racheter la
terre
l'héritage nous on sait être là
construit pour nous c'est nécessaire
pour moi à ce moment-là parce que tu
arrives arrive pas mal de problèmes
ce terrain de ma famille donc montée
d'un démarrage de création aussi à ce
moment là et puis vettel a fait erévan
notamment donc le tout la la concorde un
peu au même moment
il raconte l'histoire et famille shannon
et familles créoles descendants
d'engager qu'on appelait la réunion où
l'idée c'est alain pons voyage à travers
l'intimité de cette famille rencontré
des personnes cette famille comme
cityville bonne mutuelle épisode façon
de la combattre ici pour en ajouter
sayo julien il paie ses épaules les pros
[Musique]
notre email à court de soutier membres
on y entend la cause et
[Musique]
et alors
il est muté à découvrir
mon cri d'innocence
ils déboulent ici gazon là c'est plus à
l'attachement le cul on va dire qu'elle
a grandi là comme violent adp pays et
occupe son histoire donc le fait qu'ils
détruisent ça il fait mal et qu'on
connait qu'il y arrivera peut être ami
c'est ça le fait qu'ils enlèvent alloués
par dessus tout mais moi elle est triste
aujourd'hui naturel mais changent
évoluent avance mais ajuste la maison
nommée mais on parle un peu au milieu
c'est un peu comme un de ses bastions
mais où tout à l'infini les terrains
étaient vendus donc un but social a
totalement changé on est content qu'il
ait touché réunionnais